rich flavor that I didn't find in any
other brand try camels and see at a
certain point the first men came to
Westeros friend of mine had this
invention where actually almost was like
mythical or something but anyway it was
this chamber underground where you could
go and hear everything that anyone had
ever said about you behind your back but
in order to get to the best thing which
was at the like the lowermost chamber
you had to start at the worst insult and
work your way down my friend always used
to say he could never make it two steps
but I don't know I think I could make it
to the bottom maybe that's because I
have a poor imagination you guys have
just water
you
it is simply not pleasant to be
objectively observed it's like seeing a
candid photo of yourself online not
smiling or posing but simply looking the
way you apparently always do oblivious
and mush face with your mouth open it's
proof that we are visible to others that
we are seen in all our naked silliness
and stupid
in a group of friends I think it's
inevitable you're going to spend time
talking with one another about one
another behind one another's backs and
it's not always going to be nice thing
but I think it can be healthy your
friends are never going to be so perfect
that they don't act like an idiot
sometimes or repeat their own mistakes
or do other things which are so clearly
against their interests and I think it's
healthy to vent to other mutual friends
about how aggravating and crazy this
person can be if for nothing but to
ensure that in this instance the crazy
one is in you
first of all friends don't talk behind
your back so one thing is when people
talk behind your back it really shows
you what kind of friend they are first
thing to remember is that if anyone
talks behind your back they're probably
doing it cuz ur jealous other day at
lunch I was part of a whole group of
colleague colleagues in my school and we
were talking behind our boss's back I
mean like seriously it just is like is
it necessary you know just not it's not
necessary
you
look we're stalking behind someone's
back can just be playing shitty
especially when you're trying to gain
the favor of one friend at the expense
of another
these purely negative gossips are the
kinds of talk that we should try our
best to avoid and speak up against when
we hear it again as Crider says the
operative fallacy here is that we
believe that unconditional love means
not seeing anything negative about
someone but usually the fact that
friends talk behind other friends backs
is precisely because they have a stake
in the friendship and spend a lot of
time thinking about this person whom
they love talking with friends about
friends like talking with friends is the
important work of French just like
telling a friend that you love them is
as important as telling another friend
that you told your friend that you love
them so much of what we tell others is
what we want for ourselves does it have
to be as circuitous as this thank you so
much thank you this is great oh that
friend who that is name is Jake just a
friend of mine it's a great guy Daniel
instrument's gonna dance the flute Evan
harp stands for them Mancow
the drums the drums the glockenspiel the
instruments the sitar the electric
guitar and our students for some of the
lesser-known banjo and traveling